[Musique]
c'est une vraie révolution fiscale qui
émerge du pays du capitalisme
l'administration byden propose un impôt
minimum mondial sur les sociétés qui
permettrait de cibler les bénéfices de
toutes les multinationales y compris les
gars femme dont on cherchait
désespérément comment réussir à des
taxes et depuis bien longtemps
cela mettrait potentiellement un terme
au dumping fiscal traduisez concurrence
fiscale entre du pays
bye bye les paradis fiscaux ce tome ping
fiscale permet aux grosses entreprises
nous trouver la fiscalité la plus
intéressante pour installer leur siège
et rapatrier leur bénéfice
en europe on pense tout de suite à à
l'irlande qui accueille facebook apple
et compagnie fini également les
entreprises qui quittent leur propre
pays pour l'herbe plus verte du voisin
et les impôts plus léger bond maiden n'a
rien inventé
l'idée est sur la table de l'os et des
hauts depuis un moment
même si moto 2 21% proposé par les usa
et bien au dessus des attentes des pays
qui plaidait déjà pour sa mise en place
la france visée un petit 12,5 pour cent
pas étonnant donc que notre pays et
l'allemagne aient apporté leur soutien
au projet grâce à cette proposition
les états unis première puissance
mondiale envoie un message fort
notamment aux pays qui pourraient être
réfractaire à réhausser leur crise
qualité exemplaire au passage le projet
de taxe gafa de bruno le maire et
pourrait ainsi permettre au pays de
trouver les moyens financiers pour
sortir de la crise économique engendrée
par le cos vide
quoique cet impôt mondial pourrait
également pénalisé certains pays pauvres
qui ont bien besoin d'une fiscalité
attractive pour booster leurs économies
décidément qui a toujours des perdants
dans l'histoire